مين هنا شغال ومين هنا
طيب في اعداد كويسه طيب
في الحقيقه
احنا كلنا نظام التعليم بتاعنا للاسف
خلينا بندرس حاجات ملهاش علاقه بدراستنا
او لما بنتفرج عشان نشتغل للاسف بننسى ان
احنا درسناه وبنبدا من جديد
يمكن اغلب الناس هنا بعد التخرج سواء في
فتره الجامعه بيبتدي يصطدم بالواقع في
مقوله جميله جدا للون ديري بيقول التعليم
ليس اعدادا للحياه بل هو الحياه نفسه
يمكن رحلتي مع التعليم كانت رحله مختلفه
شويه انا من القاهره اتفرجت من بعد
الاعداديه وكان
نفسي اجي غير الثانويه العامه
فقررت ادرس تعليم فني وسافرت اسماعيليه
قعدت خمس سنين بدرس في مدرسه من احسن
المدارس في مصر في التعليم الفني عشان
عايز اخش هندسه زي حلم ناس كتير
اوتوماتيك بسبب التنسيق والداني كليه
تربيه نوعيه جامعه بورسعيد ملهاش علاقه
خالص باللي انا درست
وبعد ما خرجت من الكليه بتقدير امتياز مع
مرتبه الشرف وكنت معتقد كده ان انا مؤهل
لنوايا الدفعه عندي ان انا الاقي شغل كانت
الصدمه بالنسبه لي
[موسيقى]
اللي انت كتبتها في الجامعه دي غير مناسبه
لسوق العمل ودي كانت الصدمه بالنسبه لي
يمكن خلال شغلي في مجال التعليم او في
خلال اشتغلت في القطاع
اشتغلت في القطاع الخاص واسست بعض الشركات
اللي شغاله حتى الان في مصر وفي بعض الدول
كلنا مؤمنين ان التعليم لازم يتغير ولو
التعليم ما اتغيرش للاسف ما فيش اي حاجه
من اللي احنا بنشوفها هيحصل فيها تطور لان
في بعض المهن وبعض التخصصات اللي بداتها
مهنه زي مهنه خدمه العملاء كمان كم سنه مش
هتبقى
بعض الوظائف وبعض المهن هيتم استبدالها
برغوت هو اللي هيقوم ببعض الوظائف بس
السؤال هنا
هو احنا ليه اصلا محتاجين نطور اساليب
التعليم
كلنا في فتره العمليه التعليميه اللي بتمر
بها خلال فتره المدرسه او الجامعه احنا
بندرس حاجات كتير بس مش عارفين بندرسها
ليه او هنستخدمها امتى او هنستخدمها فين
فبالتالي الموضوع عباره عن مجموعه معلومات
بتتحط في دماغك بتخش الامتحان بتفضي
المعلومات بتاخد الشهاده وحتى الشهاده دي
ما بقاش معت
حسب التفاصل بتاعك ويمكن للاسف ان كل حد
مننا في العمليه التعليميه مختلف حضراتكم
كل حد منكم في شخص حسي في شخص حركي في شخص
بصري في حد بيستقبل المعلومه من شخص
للتاني بشكل مختلف ففكره النمطيه او ان
احنا بنتحط في قالب تعليمي وكلنا بناخد
نفس المعلومات بنفس الشكل للاسف بتطلعنا
كلنا مش فاهمين احنا بندرس ايه وبنعمل ايه
في سنه في الكليه كده بننزل بعض المدارس
عشان نتقابل مع الطلبه بيبقى فتره اسمها
تربيه العملي فنزلت بعض المدارس ولكن كانت
الصدمه برضو الطلبه بيدرسوا
بيروحوا المدرسه بس مش عارفين بيدرسوا ليه
رجعني لنفس الفتره اللي كنت بدرس فيها في
مدرسه كويسه جدا بس مش عارف التخصصات اللي
بدرسها دي ايه فايدتها
ومن هنا بدات اخد بالي من مشكله بس قبل ما
نتكلم عن تطوير التعليم احنا لازم نعرف هو
مين المؤثرين في العمليه التعليميه خلينا
نمسك الاول مدير المدرسه يمكن مدير
المدرسه ده مش دوره اللي هو الامور
الاداريه بس دوره ان هو يعرف اكتر ايه
المشاكل اللي بقابل الطلبه ايه الحاجات
اللي المدرسين محتاجين يطوروا من نفسها
يبتدي يعرفهم ويخلي الطلبه تشارك اكتر في
مسابقات في منافسات بتحصل على مستوى
العالم ويمكن لو شايفين ان ده بعيد فيمكن
في باطل من الفترات قابلت مدير مدرسه في
محافظه السويس في مدرسه حكوميه الطلبه
بتوعه بيتنافسوا على مستوى العالم في بعض
المسابقات اللي لها علاقه
وكلهم بيحققوا مراكز على مستوى العالم من
محافظه بامكانيات ضعيفه جدا
المدرس
الفكره ان المدرس النهارده ما بقاش دور ان
هو يحفظ شويه معلومات يروح يديهم للطالب
وبعد المعلومات دي يختبرهم فيهم سواء في
امتحان ترم ولا امتحان نص سنه ولا امتحان
اخر السنه وهكذا لو في الجامعه دور المعلم
هنا دلوقتي ان هو يبقى ميسر يبقى بيتابع
العمليه التعليميه يبتدي يعرف ايه ميول
الطلبه ويبتدي يشتغل عليهم ويراعي الفروق
الفرديه ما بينهم لان كل طالب قدامه له
طريقه معينه عشان يعرف يستقبل المعلومه
كمان يعرف يستخدم المنصات التعليميه اللي
النهارده بقينا نسمع عن الموكس والاوبن
اونلاين كورسز ان التعليم بقى متاح حوالين
العالم في اي مدرس يقدر ان هو يعرف الطلبه
بتوعه او يديهم مصادر تعلم يتعلموا من
خلاله
كمان يبقى ملم بالتخصصات بتاعته النهارده
مش هينفع مدرس لماده المات وما يبقاش عارف
ان الماده دي للاسف بيحصل فيها تطورات او
بيحصل فيها بعض التغيرات اللي بتحصل او
المصطلحات الجديده
الطلبه
يمكن الطالب احنا دايما بنعتقد ان الطالب
هو دور ان هو يستقبل معلومات لا الطالب
النهارده محتاج يبقى عارف ايه هي مهارات
البحث ازاي استخدم بعض المواقع عشان ادور
على المعلومه ازاي اعرف التخصص بتاعي ده
وابتدي اقدم على بعض
التدريب الصيفي او الانترني في بعض
الشركات عشان خاطر ابتدي اطور من مهاراتي
ويمكن خليني اسالكم سؤال كم حد هنا
الانشطه الطلابيه اثرت في حياته
واحده من الحاجات اللي مهمه جدا الطالب
يشتغل عليها ويبتدي يعرف اهميتها هو
الانشطه الطلابيه ويمكن فرقت في حياه ناس
كتير جدا وفرقت معي انا في خلال شغلي او
في خلال مراحل حياتي
الاهل
مش معنى انك دخلت ابنك او بنتك مدرسه من
تلات حروف او مدرسه دوليه ان انت كده قمت
بدورك احب اقول لك ان انت النهارده دورك
ان انت محتاج تعرف ابنك ميوله ايه
اهتماماته ايه المواد اللي بياخدها الكسور
اللي عنده ابتدي يعرف المتابعه بتاعته بقت
بعض المدارس بتعرفك المتابعه ابنك وتقييم
ابنك والنهارده كل اب او كل ام ملزمه ان
هي تعرف ابنها اللي بيتعلمه ده ازاي ممكن
اوريه له فلو بقى يدرس حاجه له علاقه
بالتاريخ او الجغرافيا ممكن اصفره محافظه
ما يشوف الحاجات دي لو بيدرس حاجه لها
علاقه بالتاريخ ممكن اوري له الحاجات دي
من خلال لينك او ان انا اخليه يزور بنفسه
ابتدي اشتغل على الحواس بتاعته ابتدي
اشتغل على المواد اللي هو بيدرسها
المؤسسات المعنيه بتطوير التعليم يمكن انا
على مدار العشر سنين اللي بشتغلهم في مجال
اللي اشتغلتهم في مجال التعليم بس مع جمله
كبيره جميله جدا تطوير التعليم بس تطوير
التعليم للاسف اغلب المؤسسات دول محتاجين
فعلا ان هو يبقى في تعاون معهم فانا بقترح
ان المؤسسات تبتدي تقعد مع بعضها نبقى
عارفين عايزين نطلع لا طلبه شكلها عامل
ازاي بعد كم سنه في وقت قد ايه عشان انهي
محافظه عشان المستقبل مصر ولا عشان خاطر
المستقبل العالمي لان النهارده بقينا نسمع
عن مدارس المستقبل وكل المدارس اللي احنا
فيها والاماكن دي كلها هتتبدل بحاجات
جديده فلو المؤسسات ما بقتش عارفه ايه
اللي هي عارفه انت هتطلعه يبقى في تعاون
ما بينها ويبقى في ترابط والا مش هيحصل
تطوير ويمكن النهارده لما بدات بعض
المؤسسات تشتغل على ده بقينا نسمع النماذج
كويسه بقينا نسمع عن المدارس التطبيقيه
وبقينا نسمع عن المدارس التكنولوجيه
وبقينا نسمع عن الجامعات التكنولوجيه
وبقينا نسمع عن الكليات التعليم التقني كل
الحاجات دي انا عارف ان هي بذره في مشروع
كبير كلنا محتاجين نشارك فيه
وده لان تطوير التعليم مش هيكتفي بس على
المؤسسات
طيب
هو ايه اللي هيحصل لو اساليب التعليم ما
اتطورتش
لو اساليب التعليم ما اتطورتش للاسف
الطلبه مش هتبتدي تهتم اكتر ان هي تروح
المدرسه او الجامعه بالتالي نسبه البطاله
هتلر هتزيد بالتالي الاقتصاد بتاعنا او
الناتج بتاعنا هيتاثر فكل حاجه من دي
هتاثر علينا بالسلب وبدل ما المدرس
والمدير هيبقى دورهم ان هم يلقنوا
المعلومات بل بالعكس النهارده دورهم
هيختفي وهنسمع عن بعض المهن بتاعتهم اللي
بيتم استبدالها دلوقتي بمنصات تعليميه
بتقوم بدور المدرس وبدور المعلم بشكل او
باخر والطالب بيتعلم من اي مكان هو عايزه
فبالتالي هتبقى نقطه سلبيه
طيب
ان اثر الناتج اللي
هيحصل لما نغير اساليب التعليم مبدئيا
نسبه الطلاق
ايه علاقه نسبه الطلاق بالموضوع يمكن
خلينا اسالكم هو احنا في خلال العمليه
التعليميه لما بنروح الاهالي بيروحوا
المدارس بيودوا عيالهم المدارس وبيصرفوا
اقصى ما عندهم وبيعيشوا في ضغوطات نفسيه
وفي بعض الاهالي اللي بتبتدي تاخد قرود
وتاخد سلف عشان خاطر يدخل ابنه او بنته
وده بيعمل توتر في البيت وبالتالي بياثر
كمان على البطاله لان لما الطلبه دول لما
هيتخرج مش هيلاقي شغل فبالتالي مش هيبقى
معاه دخل فبالتالي هياثر عليك يمكن
الموضوع شويه مرتبط بعوامل كتير جدا بس
خلينا نعرف
خلال السنين اللي جايه ما حصلش فيه تطوير
للاسف الفجوه الزمنيه اللي ما بينا وما
بين العالم بتزيد لان النهارده كل العالم
بيتجه في اتجاه واحنا للاسف بنرجع لورا
ولو احنا ما بداناش ان احنا نشارك في
التطوير ده ونساعد على ان العمليه
التعليميه تبقى احسن جوه مدارسنا وجوه
جامعاتنا وجوه الاكاديميات اللي بنتعلم
عنها للاسف هنطلع ناس منسوخين ولكن مش
عارفين يواجهوا التغير وبيقابلوا كتير
مشاكل حتى في فتره التعيينات لما بنيجي
نشوف ناس معينه بنعاني ان احنا نلاقي ناس
كوالي فايت عندها اللي يخلينا نشغلهم
ونبتدي نستثمر فيهم وبالتالي كل حاجه من
دول هترفليكت علينا كمان الاستثمار في
التعليم النهارده المؤسسات العالميه او
احنا لما بنحب نستثمر في التعليم بنستثمر
في المكان اللي فيه صلاحيات وفي اجراءات
فدور الدوله في الفتره دي ان هي تيسر
للناس كل المعوقات اللي انا اقدر اعمل
مؤسسه تعليميه او اعمل مكان تعليم مقنن
ومرخص وماشي على المعايير التعليميه لان
الاهل محتاجين ان ولادهم يتعلموا كويس مش
كل واحد مننا بيبقى ابوه او امه بعد
الفتره الدراسه خايف عليه عايز يضمن له
شغلانه مش عايزه يتبهدل تاني وكل واحد من
دول بيبتدي يعمل اقصى ما عنده ولكن اللي
اتكلمنا عنهم دول والاشخاص المؤثرين في
العمليه التعليميه اللي انا جاي اقوله
النهارده ان كل حد مننا لازم له دور لان
النهارده لو انت مشاركتش في تطوير التعليم
في الدايره بتاعتك او في المؤسسه بتاعتك
او في المكان اللي انت بتحبيه للاسف كل ده
هياثر عليك هياثر ان انت مش هتلاقي عمال
عندك في الشركه عندك او مش هتلاقي فنيين
في المصنع عندك او مش هتلاقي دك تخصص
بتاعك كل ده هياثر عليه وده للاسف هيخلينا
بنعيش ماضي الدول واحنا التطور اللي بيحصل
بيجري وكل العالم دلوقتي بيتكلم عن كل
التخصصات بتنزل تخصصات جديده فاحنا
بالتالي هنعيش ماضي البعض لدول فكلنا انا
وانت بنشارك في تطوير التعليق بشكل او
باخر خلال الرحله دي هي مسئوليه علينا
كلنا لازم نشارك في التطوير والا هنفضل
عايشين في الماضي شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]